[Musique]
bienvenue à tous dans ce nouveau numéro
de paf nous allons parler notamment de
la situation des quartiers difficiles
des banlieues qui sont peut-être plus
atteints que d'autres par la crise de la
de lakovic et mina et pour en parler je
suis heureux de recevoir catherine
arnaud bonjour vous êtes merde donc le
défi nous appuient ce président du
conseil départemental des yvelines vous
êtes présidente d'activité activitistes
et la chance d'insertion professionnelle
des yvelines et des hauts-de-seine et
7,6 vice président de l'association des
maires ville et banlieue
florence père cas des chemises rouges au
04 au barreau de versailles
bonjour stéphane vous êtes professeur
bonjour patrice bonjour et jean charles
lajoie ni vous êtes éditeur
bonjour à tous voilà alors on va
commencer justement par cette situation
d'aidé au fonds des banlieues de la et
blake au vide avec une déclaration vous
avez fait catherine arnould qui ou dans
laquelle vous dites au fond cette crise
joli non seulement les inégalités qui
existent entre les dents sur les
différents quartiers ou pour les
différents territoires
mais elle va les aggraver et nous a
ajouté ce n'est pas saine
peut-être inquiétant je pense qu'on a
pas pris toute la mesure de ce qui va se
passer sur le territoire
alors est-ce que vous lui demandez le
d'expliciter cette phrase et oui vous
connaissez nos territoires de banlieue
c'est des territoires d'habitat social
extrêmement dense c'est un peu ce qui
les caractérise
avec énormément de gens en difficulté
d'emploi énormément d'enfants en
difficulté et puis une moyenne générale
en tout cas sur les îles basses et
quartiers difficiles c'est environ 30 à
35 % des habitants qui vivent en dessous
du seuil de pauvreté
c'est très peu de métier qui ont pu
travailler à distance et 16 et
énormément de métier fragile
voire de deux temps partiel déjà voir de
petits boulots qui ont été arrêtés
pratiquement dès le début du confinement
et puis donc ça a été deux choses
d'abord une capacité de vivre pour filer
beaucoup plus compliqué qu'ailleurs on
l'imaginé bien les logements qui ne sont
pas si grand que ça des familles
extrêmement nombreuses et plus de
relation avec ce qui fait aussi le
charme de nos quartiers c'est cette
socialisation intense et cette
solidarité intense et cette vie qui
brusquement s'est arrêté et chacun s'est
enfermé chez soi avec une vraie peur et
je pense de la peur ici a été très
marquée elles existent encore et donc il
ya vu à la fois des parents des enfants
enfermés dans des logements plus de
travail plus de charges
parce que quand on a trois quatre
enfants qui sont à la cantine et où le
coût de la cantine à
chanteloup-les-vignes par exemple le
coût le moins cher ses 47 centimes
d'euro vous imaginez bien qu'on ne
nourrit pas une famille de 85 enfants
pour 45 centimes d'euros par personne
chaque repas et deux mois c'est long et
donc ça a été une précarisation qui
s'est installée extrêmement vie un
éloignement de l'enfant des enfants de
l'école
malgré les efforts considérables ont été
faits par les enseignants et ça tout le
monde le sait ici plus qu'ailleurs mais
c est cette fracture numérique naturel
parce que peu d'ordinateurs par oublier
comment une gestion facile de l'outil
numérique et cet éloignement et puis
vous savez mon quartier ce qui les
affaiblit ce qui les a un peu sauvé
depuis des générations contrairement à
ce qu'on dit c'est tous les moyens
humains qui ont été mis autour ça se
ceux qui tiennent au quartier ce qui
tiennent aux jeunes ce qui les emmène
vers l'emploi vers la réussite
c'est un espèce de chaîne humaine avec
un certain nombre d'actions qu'ils sont
portés par des humains et là brusquement
il n'y avait plus d'humain dans nos
quartiers nos quartiers et évite
vraiment vide même si on a lu quelques
quelques moments un peu sonore est un
peu difficile la majorité du temps nos
quartiers étaient extrêmement vide et y
avait plus d'humains pour entourer ces
familles et ses enfants en difficulté et
donc ce qu'on a vu ça n'est que le 1er
mai premier petit bout de ce qu'on verra
ce que ces enfants qui ont été durement
et longuement éloigné d'une
socialisation d'une scolarisés
sion il ça va pas ils vont pas en
ressortir un deuil ses parents qui
avaient fait des efforts qui avait
réussi à trouver des petits boulots et
tout ça il ya des efforts qui sont
complètement à reprendre
il ya des gens qu'on a perdu sur place
et et c'est à mon avis dans les mois à
venir pour va voir la vraie difficulté
moi j'ai le sentiment et je suis pas une
pessimistes par nature léger sentiment
que tous les tous les efforts qu avait
été fait on trouve dans la réussite
éducative et les enseignants que j'ai
rencontré le 10 voulons être plusieurs
années devons être anéantie y avoir une
reprise a pratiquement à zéro sur
beaucoup d'endroits au fond les deux
mois de deux mois de crise c'est au fond
des années de retards ou des années de
difficultés qui sont nés de ça c'est
passé deux mois de crise ça va ça m'a
mis fin à beaucoup d'action beaucoup
d'efforts beaucoup d'enfants qui
commençaient à sortir du des difficultés
beaucoup de parents qui commençaient à
sortir des difficultés à un chemin qui
était plutôt un chemin ascendant avec
beaucoup de beaucoup de travail sur
l'emploi et l'insertion
mais vous savez bien les premiers
boulots touchés vont êtres vont être les
boulots de les boulots qui a faim qui
sont très précaires et paradoxalement
les seuls qui travaillaient sur les
territoires c'était aussi les habitants
du quartier s'étaient tous les deux tout
le travail un peu à distance qui était
fait et qui est dont on voyait par
exemple et ça a été et ça a compliqué
aussi toutes ces familles il ya eu
beaucoup de familles dont le petit
boulot de la maman qui était un boulot
pas trop précaire était perdurait et
donc des enfants qui ont été confinés
beaucoup ont été confinés ensemble parce
que le travail l hôpital le travail
le travailleur dans il y avait encore
des entreprises qui qui avait gardé à sa
bande de petits boulots et c'étaient les
petits boulots de nos habitants mais il
ya 50 ans wigan parce qu'on aurait pu
craindre aussi et qui dit des
difficultés qui est des violences
pendant le confinement n'est pas eu
tellement ça maintenant parce que les
violences sont le fait d'une minorité
toujours et et elle avait dans un bon la
seule la seule complication c'est que
ces territoires étaient vides et que on
le sait bien
ici plus qu'ailleurs la nature a horreur
du vide donc il ya un certain nombre de
jeunes mais qui sont en minorité qui ont
un peu repris la rue ici comme ailleurs
mais sinon non y avait il y avait on
était plutôt dans un dans un état de de
sédation de peur de de peur de ce virus
qui n'avaient pas de qui n'était pas
palpable et beaucoup d'affluence en plus
de cette news mais ça vous l'imaginez
qui a fait quand même que les gens se
sont enfermés ont refermé sur e mail et
c'est ça aussi que je crains c'est cette
espèce de fermement qui va qui va
laisser des traces
oui ce que vous dites au fond et
ailleurs plusieurs crises il ya
plusieurs domaines sur lesquels il ya
des difficultés notamment l'éducation
mais celui sur lequel vous avez robin le
boulot que je de craps et sud lorsque
nous appeler à socialisation c'est à
dire le rapport à l'autre au fond un oui
absolument
les dogs no dans nos collectivités dans
notre territoire un peu fragile
c'est vrai que c'est la socialisation
fait kiffer la scolarisation par exemple
de l'enfant c'est d'abord et surtout une
socialisation c'est c'est le groupe et
c'est le groupe d des intervenants qui
sont enseignants qu'ils soient
animateurs qu'ils soient associatifs
dont c'est le seul coeur de métier c'est
eux qui font la socialisation de
l'enfant essentiellement c'est eux qui
est qui accompagne créé raccroche le la
du but en tant que parents et c'est et
c'est eux qui fabrique cette espèce de
futurs adultes beaucoup plus enfin
beaucoup plus ici qu'ailleurs et cdcc
mais c'est pour ça qu'il ya autant
d'actions et justement cette
socialisation elle a pas eu lieu et deux
mois est sans doute un peu plus que deux
mois parce qu'il se trouve que en plus
nos territoires malgré tout ce qu'on a
fait comme efforts pour rendre relancer
les l'ouverture des écoles les écoles
sont ouverts par exemple le 25
pratiquement tous les niveaux de toutes
les écoles de chant trous seront
ouvertes ce qui l'est ce qui laisse
supposer vraiment car il ya eu un effort
de tous des enseignants de la ville et
tout mais malgré ça la peur est encore
prégnante et il ya entre 18 et 20%
seulement des parents qui ont qui ont
vécu en a qui sont sortis de leur peur
ou qui ont accompagné les enfants vers
l'école
donc vous voyez je pense que cette ce
confinement il n'est pas fini dans les
esprits comment ce mercredi
puisqu'on en est aux tableaux d'aidé au
fonds des difficultés vous avez un peu
d'observation qui est celui de tvo capte
en droit social
on craint beaucoup et c'est un peu la
suite de ce que disait catherine arnoux
on craint beaucoup de licenciements dans
les dents les semaines dans les mois qui
viennent oui moi je suis déjà consulté
depuis donc il ya moi notamment alors
déjà premièrement sur les ruptures des
périodes d'essai à dire que tous les
salariés car on était en période d'essai
dont la bête décès a été suspendue en
cas de chômage partiel reviennent
maintenant dans l'entreprise qui se dit
que c'est pas le moment garder des gens
disent peu derrière moi peut-être faire
des licenciements économiques il ya des
ruptures de période d'essai qui sont
parfaitement illégales
la rupture doit se faire sur la
compétence du salarié et non pas parce
qu'on a des problèmes de trésorerie des
problèmes économiques
donc va y avoir ce premier à ce propos
des problèmes là j'ai dû voir dizaine ou
une quinzaine d'entreprises concédé à ce
type de tir de patrice et ensuite j'ai
aux entreprises qui ont demandé de les
accompagner à la rentrée au mois de
septembre pour faire des essais et
licenciés dont encodant et 50 salariés
parce que pas ce qui va arriver à
maintenir les postes et à payer ses
salariés la vois bien les annonces qui
sont faites sur des 30 entreprises sur
les plans qui vont être mis en place que
ce soit renault avec les fermetures de
sites ou air france qui va licencier
également mais dans les petites
entreprises et moyennes entreprises
c'est exactement la même chose c'est pas
de mention au niveau des universités pas
de poste d'observation vous avez
l'université est ce que vous voyez aussi
une sorte de fracture sociale ou de 2,2
de fracture qui se disent produits oui
donc au sein de cette société et que le
et que en effet la crise du virus a
aggravé oui patrice elle et elle est
relativement net cette fracture entre
nos jeunes étudiants les étudiants les
plus les plus expérimentés on sait
pertinemment qu'avec les mets
kahnisme d'enseignement à distance aussi
perfectionné soit il
en dépit des efforts assez considérables
qui ont été faits par beaucoup de
beaucoup de collègues et beaucoup
d'enseignants d'ailleurs quel que soit
le niveau
dans l'enseignement primaire secondaire
et supérieur il ya eu des efforts tout à
fait considérables qui ont été faits
mais on sait aussi par l'expérience et
on l'a vu on l'a vu jouer à la faveur de
deux des derniers événements que les ce
qu'on appelle les décrocheurs si vous
voulez ont été ont été beaucoup plus
nombreux on sait pertinemment qu'un
certain nombre plus non plus une marge
relativement importante de nos étudiants
de première année ne se sont pas
connectés aux divers renseignements ou
exercice qu'on proposait à distance on
sait que le les acquis que le capital
social que le capital culturel des
familles dans lesquelles ces étudiants
peuvent vivre on sait que les conditions
matérielles dans lesquelles vivent ou
ont une influence considérable sur sur
leur aptitude à pouvoir suivre à
distance un certain nombre
d'enseignements et on l'a vu donc au
cours des dernières semaines
on sait que tout cela était
considérablement accentué continue sur
ce constat après on va peut-être parler
d'aider des remèdes et d aider des
politiques qu'il faudrait mener sur le
constat justement de cette fracture de
territoire quel est votre sentiment
là-dessus mais moi je suis très étonné
enfin presque sidérés par les propos de
madame le maire que je ne conteste pas
du tout mais c'est un constat qui est
terrifiant faire que de penser que deux
mois à vous écouter deux mois ruines
quasiment toute une vie et deux mois me
paraissent quand même
certes compliqué c'est pour ça que je
trouve est extrêmement intelligent de la
part du gouvernement de rouvrir les
écoles en dépit de ce que beaucoup de
gens ont critiqué est tout à fait
indispensable pour récupérer ses enfants
pour redonner du lien social etc
mais quand vous dites que deux mois en
tout mis par terre je me dis mais c'est
ça paraît dantesque
alors est-ce que
québec quelle est la véritable coup
est-ce que je ne peux pas imaginer qu'en
deux mois je veux dire tout se délite
tous ces faux ça ça me paraît ça me
paraît un peu exagéré alors peut-être
que c'était dramatique déjà bien avant
et que c'est simplement le la goutte
d'eau qui fait déborder le vase mais
j'ai du mal à concevoir aimé mais je
vous crois volontiers que que en deux
mois tout se soit effondré alors que
c'est peut-être pas effondré mais mais
mais sa situation s'est aggravée en tout
cas c'est ce que vous disiez à gabriel
hardy et juste au final parce que moi je
sais des étudiants aussi en iut
effectivement cette fracture sociale
existe cette fracture informatique plus
qu'une fracture sociale mais je suis
absolument bluffé par le certains
étudiants qui au début effectivement eu
un peu de mal à reconnaître et presque
avoué que chez eux
l'informatique c'était était le niveau
zéro qui avait pas de possibilité etc
mais aisée sur l'a81 d'étudiants que je
suis avec lequel on travaille
régulièrement il y en a au moins trois
ou quatre qui sont totalement démunis de
façon informatique on a essayé de
trouver des solutions pour certains on
va trouver et pour les autres ils font
leurs devoirs de façon manuscrite sa
demande effectivement plus de travail
mais il travaille autant que les autres
n'y a pas du tout ce rejet en disant je
n'ai pas l'informatique je travaille pas
je me réfugie pas du tout au contraire
ils sont à rentrer en s'excusant nous
écoutez je suis désolé je veux pas vous
rendre un truc hyper propres etc
j'ai un papier un crayon des stylos j'ai
des feuilles et les devoirs marib
scanner c'est des captures d'écran faite
par leur téléphone etc
donc il ya une appétence pour le savoir
ne pas être laissé sur le côté de ces
étudiants qui se trouve ça absolument
bluffant et tout à fait tout à fait
l'euphorie zan parce que vraiment ils
travaillent et bombe a effectivement je
reçois quelques devoirs sur des feuilles
avec une écriture communiste plus
personne est habitué à écrire mais
l'écriture qui font un peu malhabile sur
3 ou 4 3 ou 4 copies doubles enfin ça
devient compliqué mais en tout cas qui
chapeaute ces étudiants qui ne se laisse
pas déroutés par set
cette misère informatique
on parle juste sur un témoignage
mon mari donne des cours à des enfants
qui sont en primaire sur des cours de
soutien qui la donne et au long du
confinement il continue maintenant parce
qu'effectivement il ya des parents qui
ont peur voire même des enfants de
primaire qui ont peur aussi qu'ils ne
veulent pas retourner à l'école et la
difficulté à gm c'est que dans un petit
espace à quatre enfants il ya qu un seul
ordinateur évidemment il faut qu' il
faut que le gamin soit vraiment tenace
et qui les avons une volonté de fer pour
pouvoir travailler alors que la télé
fonctionne que les autres gamins sont
derrière sont du bruit et il faut qu'ils
arrivent à se mettre dans une bulle pour
pouvoir avancer donc c'est compliqué et
effectivement je pense que à deux mois
détruire à des années de travail comme
là on voit bien l'impact d'un kobe de 19
sur les entreprises où il ya ces des
années de travail qui peuvent ruiner des
entreprises ont de moi c'est un peu un
peu la même chose et je pense que des
élèves en difficulté petits ou au
collège ont peut-être pas la même vie
que l'étudiant jean-charles sont déjà il
n'est pas tout à fait dans la même
configuration l'analogique les
entreprises est un peu différent ce
qu'une entreprise sans ce type
d'affaires s'effondre on comprend bien
voilà non je pense que le laki de d'un
enfant ne s'effondre pas en deux mois en
tout cas j'espère alors catherine r non
justement
je rebondis un petit peu sur ce que
disait jean charles lajoie ni mais c'est
vrai que il ya une politique de la ville
combat depuis des années et des
gouvernements successifs ont mené une
politique différente de la ville vous
même vous étiez membre de la commission
borloo est ailleurs des propositions qui
avaient été proposées par cette
commission n'ait pas été retenue par le
par le présent
les mais c'est vrai qu'on a l'impression
d'un puits sans fond c'est à dire qu'à
chaque fois il faut recommencer et que
on n'arrive pas à trouver des solutions
c'est faux on arrive à trouver des
solutions individuelles
le seul problème c'est que la lecture
que les extérieurs ont de la politique
de la ville c'est une espèce de lecture
de territoire et non pas une lecture par
individu quand vous aussi on avait fait
depuis le départ et et on ne l'a pas
fait si on l'avait fait depuis le départ
a suivi de famille qui vivait sur ces
territoires politique de la ville on
aurait vu parce que nous on le voit tous
n'auraient vu que c'est une pente
ascendante très régulièrement et plus
les actions sont menées auprès des
familles plus ces familles réussissent
et les enfants réussissent plutôt goût
mieux ré plutôt plus d'efforts le seul
problème c'est qu'on a une lecture
territoriales et le territoire il bouge
je vais vous donner un exemple dans les
quartiers politique de la ville il ya
20% de renouvellement tous les deux ans
c'est à dire qu'en fait on le sait très
bien que les familles qui commence quai
qui sont pris en charge et qu'ils se
prennent en charge après et qui utilise
tous les dispositifs généralement qui
ces territoires desquels vont mieux et
elles sont remplacées par des familles
qui sont en difficulté de nouveaux
essais ça c'est là le puits sans fonds
c'est c'est ce qu'on appelle la
politique de peuplement c'est une
politique est depuis 20 ans toujours la
même un peu plus forte dans l'île de
france et autour des grosses métropoles
c'est que les lieux deux quartiers
populaires d'habitat social danse comme
les nôtres sont encore les lieux où on
peut où il ya du mouvement et où on peut
retrouver du logement vous savez que
cette pénurie de logements dans l'île de
france de logement social de france fait
en fait la politique de peuplement donc
la politique d'habitat porté par l'état
remet les familles les plus en
difficulté sur les territoires les plus
en difficulté et malgré toutes les
volontés dit depuis des années rien n'a
changé
rien n'a changé donc en fait famille par
famille
on est toutes les actions sont efficaces
mais sur l'ensemble du territoire nous
avons nous avons des chiffres qui
s'améliore extrêmement lentement
donc en fait non on est au bruit on est
obligé nou 2-2 de prendre en charge en
fait la population qui est là sur place
à un moment donné même si celle là est
aujourd'hui ferrante et c'est celle-là
aussi qui nous permet d'évaluer qui me
permet de faire ces constats et
effectivement je recharge
effectivement quand on parle et je vais
prendre la suite de ce que disait jean
charles lajoie ni quand on tue on
s'adresse à des étudiants à des niveaux
plus élevés collèges lycées et des
gamins qui commençait à vraiment s'en
sortir plus il ya eu une volonté
extraordinaire pendant ces deux mois de
continuer et quels que soient les les
conditions même s'il n'était pas facile
à essayer de trouver des solutions et
ils ont été trouvées des solutions
d'émail heures pour être aidé mais moi
je parle du dents de l'enfant en cm1 cm2
qui spontanément note n'a pas son cadre
propre il est là le cadre qui est porté
par l'adulte par les adultes il qu'il
accompagne et vous imaginez bien non la
vue parce que il ya eu deux semaines de
confinement et deux semaines de congés
et on avait trouvé dès le départ c'était
une bêtise
puisqu'on savait que le pot film allait
durer plusieurs semaines c'était une
bêtise de ne pas cumuler tous les congés
de toute la france en même temps il sera
le plus tard possible pour qu'on ait
pris des prix à 72 rythme les deux
premières semaines avait donné un peu de
rythme les deux semaines suivantes de
congés scolaires en ile de france a
cassé le pot de rythme que les enfants
avaient pris et les enseignants nous
disent tu sais tape ça aussi que les
reconnexions et que les efforts ont été
on était un peu perdu
alors on a mis en place nous d comme
dans beaucoup de quartiers comme les
nôtres on a mis en place de
l'accompagnement pendant le temps des
vacances scolaires de l'accompagnement
en lutte en du court en sortant un peu
les enfants du confinement leur donnant
des rendez vous très précis pour se ré
accroché pour essayer pour qu'on leur
fasse comprendre un nombre de choses
qu'il n'avait pas compris pour imprimer
ce qu'ils n'avaient pas imprimer et ces
enfants-là de sa volonté avec des
parents très volontaire ceux là n'ont
pas perdu pendant la semaine les deux
semaines de vacances parce qu'ils ont eu
de nouveau un contact humain il les
acquis les awa motivé mais ceux qui ont
lâché pendant le temps des vacances
n'ont pas repris le mois d'après c'est
en tout cas ce que me disent les
enseignants et ceux qui ont dit les
principaux de collèges qui rend pourtant
fait un travail
enfin les enseignants appelée leurs
rangs les enfants tous les jours à
pratiquement tous les jours ça a été un
effort considérable de la part des
enseignants
le sait et puis à sa se rajoute mais
naturellement la culpabilité de l'enfant
qu'elle a achetés depuis deux-trois de
cuir noir et qui va pas vous dire qu'il
a lâché depuis un mois la culpabilité du
parent qui a été en difficulté mais je
sais pas si vous avez eu des parents qui
ont tout à fait la capacité à suivre les
enfants eux aussi ils étaient épuisés
doute de moi ça n'aide pas mais qui est
le métier de parent n'est pas le métier
d'enseignant un peu s'en faut - et donc
il ya aussi la culpabilité du parent qui
a lâché qu'elles achètent parce qu'ils
n'en pouvaient plus parce qu'ils
comprenaient plus parce que parce que
voilà le système pour lui demander où
l'effort polonais était bien plus
important peut-être tout ce qu'il avait
fait avant et donc cette double
culpabilité par enfant ça éloigne aussi
et les enseignants que j'ai vu dans les
écoles là me disais que les 8 10 enfants
qu'ils ont par l'école par classe parce
que ça n'est pas plus 2010 eux-mêmes
alors que du coup ce sont les enfants
restez connectés il n'est pas en volonté
puisqu'ils les ont mis alors ce il zola
et ils les hommes les anciens me disait
on a plus de mal à les remettre dans le
bain après deux mois de vacances
scolaires on vit régulièrement chaque
année et donc ça c'est un constat
enseignants donc ça n'est pas assez
c'est une vue de professionnels et et
d'ailleurs il se demande un peu ce que
tu vas être c'est à moi et demi de
scolarité dans la mesure où ils ont à
reprendre effectivement 2,3 en fait je
crois il ya eu quatre mois de scolarité
avant ils ont à reprendre 4 masculin 10
ou même le sentiment que dès que des
pertes ont été faites en ligne mais
c'est normal
ces enfants ont vécu enfermés dans une
femme dans des familles dans des petits
appartements avec du bruit une
incapacité de se concentrer et le cadre
qui n'était plus mis par le cadre
enseignant mais c'est assez normal c'est
vrai que des bd de la coupe des
enseignants et beaucoup augmenté pendant
la crise du ch de la commune et le
parents ou le parent a compris ce
qu'était d'enseignants et ne se respecte
tout ça je trouve que c'est d'annoncer
le mans paulo est très positif des
naïades de confinement l'enseignant a
compris ce que c'est d'être parents mais
le parloir vraiment compris le métier
d'enseignant et ça c'est je pense que ça
va laisser des traces positives dans
l'avenir petite question sociologique
quand vous parlez de famille
mais c'est quoi ces des familles
complètes c'est souvent des familles
oddo parental vous savez tous nos
territoires sont à peu près pareil va
34% selon les endroits de familles
monoparentales généralement d'ailleurs
commencé des familles monoparentales
c'est souvent des mères qui ont un petit
emploi mais qui ont un emploi qui vont
continuer à l'exercer
mais c'est les familles nombreuses oui
l'habitat social ces fêtes de famille
nombreuse 3 4 5 6 1 en quoi c'est c'est
la moyenne c'est maintenant sont
justement sur scène politique de la
ville alors qui est qui depuis depuis je
crois mitterrand il ya des ministres de
la ville
il ya eu des politiques avec beaucoup de
budgets d'ailleurs on a l'impression en
effet comme le disait katrina peut-être
qu'on a on a travaillé sur les
territoires plutôt que sur les individus
on n'a pas trouvé le bon curseur sur
cette politique de la ville alors je je
sais pas si on n'a pas trouvé le bon
curseur fin toujours est il il ya moi je
vois vraiment comme ça deux observations
qui viennent c'est que la première c'est
qu'on on a fait de la politique de la
ville
un emblème un marqueur politique assez
fort souvenez vous et c'est tout un
symbole bernard tapie à une dénommée
avait été en son temps de ministre de la
ville par par françois mitterrand
c'était là vraiment un symbole un
symbole assez fort d'ailleurs à beaucoup
de points de vue et puis ma seconde
observation c'est qu'une politique
publique comme celle là ne peux et
madame le maire l'expliquer ne peut
produire de de résultats que sur le
moyen sinon le très long terme parce qu
en effet c'est une espèce de puits sans
fond le alors certains nous ont quand
même laissé laissé des traces
relativement relativement positive on
parlait évidemment de jean louis borloo
tout à l'heure le plan borloo initiale a
pris vraiment la question à bras le
corps il faut une volonté politique
extrêmement forte
il y à une question aussi de
coordination avec de toute évidence avec
les élus locaux avec le
avec je n'aime pas cette expression mais
avec ce qu'on appelle le terrain qui me
gêne pas cette expression parce qu'on
sait pas trop ce que c'est que je n'ai
en tout cas avec les élus locaux
ce type de politique nationale c'est une
politique nationale parce qu'il ya des
moyens questions qui sont considérables
doivent être mobilisés mais on ne peut
pas ne peut pas ne peut livrer ne peut
produire aucun succès sans une
concertation sans une autre chose sans
un coup au portage comme on dit parfois
très étroits avec les élus locaux ça
c'est une
c'est une certitude jean pierre jeunet
une question c'est vrai qu'on a on a eu
l'impression
on parle de deux lot de la différence
est parfois des inégalités entre les
territoires et donc pendant le
confinement il ya eu de la part de la
police
des comportements différents donc on a
laissé un petit peu vivre un peu plus
dans certains quartiers difficiles parce
qu elle pas tout à fait malade ni
d'ailleurs je pense que c'est indéniable
enfin entendu personne ne le niez et
enfin des officiers de police sont là
nombreux à témoigner en disant on nous a
clairement dit que c'était pas la peine
d'intervenir dans certains lieux dans
certains quartiers parce que de toute
façon intervenir ça allait déclencher
des rixes des bagarres b et que nous ne
saurions pas suffisamment nombreux et ce
serait une contre-productif d'aller au
contact donc on a un peu laissé tomber
de 2,2 dans ces quartiers parce que très
souvent c'est parce qu'enfin le maire
mais c'est que il ya un constat qui est
toujours de dire mais non mais à chaque
fois qu'on voit quelque chose
d'important vous le disiez vous et
madame le maire tout à lyon dans
quelques points de chaleur mais moi
c'est des points de salaire qui est ce
que je trouve un peu effrayant parce
qu'à chaque fois on m'a dit russe et un
petit point de chaleur etc
on voit des c'est pas partout et
heureusement mais quand on voit des
camions de pompiers recevoir des
frigidaires sur le sur le capot lloris
est un point de chaleur ces deux cas le
dit avec les pompiers mais franchement
je veux dire et est-ce que de toujours
minimisé des choses c'est pas encore
mettre la poussière sous le tapis du
débat on verra bien plus tard peut-être
qu'à un moment il faut aussi reconnaître
qu'il ya plus que des moments de chaleur
il ya des cartes et qui deviennent
peut-être des zones de non droit et que
c'est extrêmement désagréable surtout
pour les gens qui habitent
parce que comme vous le disiez très
justement
mais c'est une minorité agissante qui
plombe l'avis d'une majorité qui est
obligé de se taire et de et de faire
bonne figure malgré la situation
cette majorité là quelques par les ans
catherine arnaud d'ailleurs mais on est
très claire premièrement je ne peut pas
résumer ces quartiers politique ville
assez 5% qui nous pourrissent la vie je
ne peux pas le résumer puisque c'est
tout le regard extérieur qui du coup est
pollué et c'est tous les habitants qui
sont une digue des victimes de plus donc
mon propos est clair pour ça que mon
propos est clair pour le deuxième
la deuxième partie c'est
qu'effectivement oui c'est 5% qui
pourrissent la vie des habitants lors
leurs agissements et insupportable mais
c'est pas l'élu local qui a capacité à
les arrêter ces agissements on est bien
d'accord un ça va bien au dessus de la
sava bien l'outil de l'élu local c'est à
la fois police justice police dans ces
grandes difficultés et justice dansant
danser dans ses obligations mais c'est
très compliqué pour un élu local de deux
à la fois de dire 95 % de mes habitants
méritent une attention très important
parce qu'ils n'ont plus de difficultés
et plus de mérite ailleurs il faut une
espèce de protection obligatoire et et
mais de dire aussi que les agissements
insupportables les attaques de pompiers
de policiers dé lui aussi parce que nous
sommes maintenant par le représentant de
l'autorité
oui c'est insupportable ça ne doit pas
être toléré ça ne doit vous êtes doit
être tolérée par personne sur le
territoire national et du coup
effectivement là on n'est plus dans
l'accompagnement on est obligatoirement
la sanction je suis assez d'accord avec
vous et aidez votre part dans quelle est
votre position et quelle est la
situation surtout les lignes avec la
police municipale d'une police
municipale les comment est ce que ça
fonctionne chaleur y avait une police
municipale à fresnes c'est fragile elle
n'existe plus pour tout un tas de
raisons
des arrêts maladie des grossesses
dévoile adp pa nous sommes en train de
remonter une police municipale
mais la police municipale quand elle
sera remontée et est un peu costaud le
seul substitut qui aura jamais la police
nationale ça n'est pas son métier et
d'autre part c'est dangereux parce qu'à
un moment donné il faut que les il faut
que les métiers et les obligations de
chacun soit respecté
alors justement je vois pas combien
maintenant peut-être aux solutions
je veux rappeler que vous êtes la
présidente activity la taille pour
l'insertion professionnelle dans des
rôles et on les yvelines dans les
hauts-de-seine question les mesures
d'urgence vous avez prises ou dont vous
avez besoin alors sur le plan de
l'emploi de l'insertion parce que vous
savez qu activité et donc à lagence
d'insertion qui est qui et le voir mais
voilà maintenant des deux départements
il vinet et hauts-de-seine la première
les premières décisions que nous avons
prises n'étaient pas moine c'est de se
dire tous les chantiers d'insertion tout
l'économie sociale et solidaire qui
portent des emplois d'insertion toutes
les à la fois les entreprises et les
associations d'insertion vont être
extrêmement fragilisée par ce temps
qu'ils mettent un temps mort on
imaginait bien le 16 mars qu on aime
qu'on partait pas pour vigion à emporter
pour plusieurs semaines voire plusieurs
mois
notre première action c'était simple
mais on l'a décidé vite c'est de
financer extrêmement rapidement 3
millions d'euros de subventions qui
étaient adonnés au tout au fil du temps
de l'année 2020 nous avons fait un
conseil d'administration exceptionnel de
façon à financer vos tweets et
d'associations pour les sécuriser
entre toutes celles qui avaient des
emplois et et dont il fallait mettre
qu'il allait mettre en chômage partiel
et après ça a été alors sans compter le
lien permanent avec l'entreprise avec
association parce qu'il fallait aussi
sécuriser tout le monde y compris sur le
plan psychologique
l'attention a été portée sur tout toutes
les options d'insertion toutes les infos
médiation qu'ils pouvaient continuer à
travailler et il y en a eu et celles qui
pouvaient se développer en trouvant de
nouveaux métiers
je vais vous donner deux exemples
on a une association qui s'agace et
erquy à conflans sainte honorine et qui
fait qu' entre autres fait des jardins
avec jardin de cocagne à plusieurs
endroits quimerc'h d'insertion par le
phénomène de de l'agriculture voilà du
potager donc il ya un certain nombre de
postes en insertion elle s'est
développée après dans des boutiques de
proximité des boutiques solidaires bio
plus puisque le travail et c'est bio des
boutiques solidaires demandé
on a certainement des territoires il y
en a une à chanteloup les vignes et bien
il fallait absolument faire perdurer que
ces emplois continuer ce travail là avec
la tension et la distance continuer à
faire vivre ces petits c lieu de laisser
lieu de vie ces lieux de vente
parce que du coup il y avait un double
avantage c'est que c'était en proximité
une capacité de fournir et là c'est dans
le village de chanteloup de fournir de
la nourriture des légumes voilà donc en
fait on a il ya sept postes en insertion
qui ont été confortées et les gens sont
continuer à en conduire à venir
travailler dans cette danse et
entreprises de continuité et puis il ya
eu par exemple de la création
d'entreprise dans deux villes pas très
loin de chez moi dans une halle quartier
politique de la vie cette même
association après un grand chantier de
fabrication de masques vraiment postes
en insertion qui ont été mis il a fallu
fournir activity a fourni les moyens et
puis après la foule il fallait fournir
l'investissement et ça va être du métier
durable ce qui était du métier
provisoire de l'opportunité peut-être
mais heureusement quand cette
opportunité valait parfaite des métiers
durables un avantage aussi c'est que
c'est beaucoup de métiers féminins vous
savez que les chantiers d'insertion face
pour le public féminin c'est ce qui est
plus compliqué et donc là on a on à
l'ouverture sans doute de 40 postes et
un certain nombre de postes définitive
voilà donc comment se positionner à la
demande des entreprises associations
l'économie sociale et solidaire va être
extrêmement durement touchés et du coup
elle heureusement elle bénéficié elle
aussi du prêt garanti d'état parce que
parce que vous savez que c'est celle des
entreprises qui sont essentiellement
financée par l'état qui sont comme
toujours des équilibres très précaires
et pour lequel à terme de chantier ont
été
est mort et je vous donne un exemple le
relais que tout le monde connaît la
grande entreprise et à chanteloup elle
est à la rai complètement les par
l'arrêt d'une façon que volontaire
l'état l'arrêt parce que parce que là
les la suite de ces projets l'intention
d'envoyer l'ensemble des lanceurs de la
fabrication d'une part et elle même donc
il ya plus de 100 personnes qui sont à
l'arrêt depuis depuis le mois de mars
et c'est cette entreprise solidaire du
coup n'est figé dans le temps il faut
aussi les aider financièrement à
reprendre du souffle comme une
entreprise choisie est normal on se perd
quel est ce que justement pour les
entreprises y avait il ya des des
décisions de justice qui sont moins
radicale suspense aux fermetures au
faillite éventuelle qu'elles ne le sont
en temps normal
ou est ce que la justice applique comme
elle ne s'applique que habituellement
pendant la période de confinement elle a
été dans ce cas de dépôt de bilan
elle a été très à l'écouté des chefs
d'entreprise et à essayer de mettre en
place non pas de redressement judiciaire
ou de liquidation judiciaire et des
plans de sauvegarde
il permet normalement pour pouvoir avoir
un plan de sauvegarde il faut pas être
en état de cessation témoins il y avait
des entreprises qui étaient en état de
cessation témoin puisqu'elle payer plus
urssaf les cotisations retraite etc
il ya eu un soutien de la part des des
juges du tribunal de commerce pour
essayer de les porter et qu'elles
arrivent à se sortir de cette ornière
le plan de sauvegarde duré six mois et
après on peut voir sur le poursuivre
avec des plans d'étalement des dettes ce
qui normalement est pas tout à fait
l'objet du plan de sauvegarde mais
l'espèce ils ont essayé d'utiliser cet
outil en tendant un peu le bras à la loi
et est du coup il ya eu un vrai soutien
de ces entreprises qui était très en
difficulté et puis après il ya le prêt
de l'état et une chez meetic ya joué son
rôle
cela étant sur les entreprises qui
étaient vraiment très exemple les prêts
n'ont pas été abîmées parce que derrière
il savait que oui continuez à bertry il
ya une grande aide au cas où via ce plan
ce prêt entreprises un mou alors avant
de passer aux autres activités parce que
c'est moi qu'on parle aussi des
municipales guerrier beaucoup de tact et
les politiques qui vous avez fait partie
catherine armes de la justice et de la
commission
la mission borloo vous avez été une de
celles qui a regretté que des travaux 4
me soit pour l'eau et étaient nés été
retoqué public et qu'elle s'était les
les des grands propositions majeures qui
selon vous aurait pu changer le cours
des choses du genre compliqué quand il
ya 20 sujets différents d'en sortir
quelques-uns puisqu'en fait ça n'était
pas là où l'autre c'était tout il y
avait une logique cas dans ce plan
certaines choses ont été reprises mais
ont été reprises plus lentement qu'il ne
l'aurait fallu
je vous donne un exemple parce que moi
j'étais sur le sujet de l'éducation la
cité éducative tels qu'on les avait
imaginées proposées elles sont en train
d'être prises à titre expérimental mais
on aime bien
elles vont peut-être avoir un du paf à
sa tête un peu compliqué avec cette
payet confinement mais mais néanmoins on
s'aperçoit là c'est juste l'exemple de
la de la façon dont on avait travaillé
en plein boulot c'est comment faire un
vrai travail de mutualisation tous les
acteurs et le principe de la cité du cat
iq c'était ça c'était les enseignants
les parents tous les métiers autour de
l'enfant dans une collectivité qui
portait un projet éducatif en s'appuyant
en trouvant les compétences de l'enfant
et en s'appuyant sur des compétences qui
étaient sans doute des compétences
différentes ce qui est est classiquement
utilisées et bien on s'aperçoit tout sur
les drogues licites éducative avait
commencé à exister
cette travail de mutualisation ce
travail de partage
c'est l'endroit sans doute où les
acteurs ont été le plus consolidée le
plus sécurisé ont pu inventer quai et
continue à travailler sur l'invention de
demain face à ses enfants
voilà donc je parle de la cité éducative
je peux parler de la cour d'équité
territoriale parce que ça ça n'est pas
rien ça n'est pas qu'un symbole c'est
aussi montrer comment des territoires
malgré tout ce qu'on dit de l'argent qui
dégouline pas ce que dieu sait si on l'a
entendu individu par individu territoire
territoire ça n'est pas du tout la
réalité c'est aussi des plans massives
d'emplois aidés et d'emplois d'insertion
il faut admettre une fois pour une fois
pour toutes que quand on parle d'emplois
aidés on parle d'emplois aidés par
l'état effectivement mais dieu sait si
de se déformer des autres les emplois
sont là largement aidé mais les emplois
qui sont ses premiers emplois
d'insertion qui sont ses premiers
emplois vont d'arriver dans un cursus
d'emplois un peu sécurisé ce temple dix
aidé c'est ce qui fait aussi tout le
lien social et tous les besoins davaï
tout les besoins et les réussites de nos
territoires
donc à un moment donné il fallait mettre
on était dans le massif on est peut-être
dans le dans l'ensemble des dents dans
l'ensemble des dispositifs et les en
fait ça allait effectivement à la fois
du vieillissement qui est plus important
et on va le voir qui est plus important
sur nos quartiers politique de la ville
sur lesquels la concentration des
personnes âgées très âgées va nous
sauter à la figure dans les territoires
entre au départ politique de la ville de
l'île de france
brad qui ont pratiquement tous été
construits dans les années 70 qui ont
été peuplée dans les années 70 c'est là
où l'on va trouver la densité de
vieillissement le plus important est de
personnes âgées le plus éloigné de tout
de la prendre en charge de la santé d'un
certain nombre de choses et là aussi
vous allez voir ça veut apparaître dans
les années à venir nous on le sait des
jeunes mais déjà les politiques en face
c'est évidemment la politique de la
petite enfance c'est celle là mais c'est
essentiellement la politique de
l'insertion et de l'emploi
vous avez compris pourquoi intervenir
deux secondes quand même monsieur pour
pourquoi cette étude ce rapport et sept
commissions ont été créées pourquoi le
lait des travaux au fond été rejeté vous
savez ce qui s'est passé ou pas alors
j'ai compris pourquoi elle avait été
créée parce que c'était nécessaire
et puis parce qu'elle m'a donné
y avait une espèce de vent qui venait de
l'ensemble de la société à la fois des
élus à la fois des associations de
certaines entreprises qui avaient montré
qu'à un moment donné fallait penser
travaille tous ensemble et on l'a fait
pendant presque six mois d'une façon
très intense ont tous les acteurs de ce
plan vous diront que ils en sont sortis
tous grandi puis ce qu'ils ont fait à la
fois des rencontres qu'ils ont et fait
évoluer leurs pensées en six mois plus
que sans doute chacun avec moi pendant
des années donc au moins sur ce plan là
on peut dire que nous nous sommes
heureux de ce plan borloo ça c'est des
vrais issoire et ça fait des vrais
partenariats du vrai projet de
territoire
pourquoi ça a été abandonnée et bien non
je ne je ne n'ai pas compris sa ponette
s'apprenait peut-être trop d'importance
enfin peu importe je vais pas faire de
la psychologie on est entre nous mais
mais néanmoins néanmoins c'était ça
aurait été nécessaire dans en plus d'y
mettre une volonté politique forte et le
le paradoxe quand même c'est quand vous
regardez vous voyez que le gouvernement
a chopé des sujets les uns derrière les
autres dans ce plan borloo
petit à petit en catimini qu'autre chose
même si maintenant ils le revendiquent
et c'est un peu dommage de ne pas
l'avoir fait ensemble tout de suite mais
je vous dis les partenaires il ya eu
énormément de grands partenariats je
vois par exemple chez nous il ya un
partenaire remarquable avec l'essec qui
était inquiète à 15 kg mais qui a
toujours été à 15 km mais c'est parce
que les gens se sont rencontrés que
l'essec avec avec sa fondation un pour
les quartiers sensibles a donné
massivement et donne encore massivement
de son savoir-faire des étudiants aussi
sur nos territoires
donc on a fait des histoires de vie et
on a créé du partenariat que l'état n'a
pas créé à deux places mais c'est pas
grave c'est aussi comme ça c'est aussi
par ces échanges de savoir faire ont
fait avancer les solutions pour notre
quartier
un mot rapide peut-être avec vous
stéphane sur le lève jamais fait j'avais
fait un mémoire est très très longtemps
sur le référé historique dans le
discours politique j'ai pêche et c'est
trop tôt les années soixante dix c'est
maintenant que je dois le faire
macron n'arrête pas de fable différé
historique du clemenceau
fait la guerre on est en guerre et puis
là il ya de gaulle la tête nation qui
meurent jamais même quand elle est à
terre qu'est ce que vous pensez de ces
références serait fait appel voix du
référé parce que le référé c'est plus
encore qu'une référence
oui vous avez raison j'aime bien cette
expression référé parce qu'elle elle
marque vraiment un aspect un peu
systémique enfin vraiment une
un mécanisme politique tout à fait tout
à fait conscient ce que j'en pense c'est
que s'ils voulaient un président de la
vème république en france
j'allais dire est parfaitement dans son
rôle et il occupe parfaitement le
fauteuil par ces mécanismes de référé
historique alors de gaulle lui-même
d'ailleurs auquel on se réfère et ces
derniers temps d'ailleurs c'est si j'ose
dire tragi comique de voir que les gens
m'aiment comme comme marine le pen en
vient à se référer au général de gaulle
enfin c'est c'est plus comique que
tragique de mon point de vue mais de
gaulle lui-même se référer de manière
assez fréquente alors non pas évidemment
assez agréable mais à 2 à de grandes
figures de l'histoire n'ont pas non plus
nécessairement à vergèze de
vercingétorix met enfin à nos grands
poètes à nos grands héros belge ouvre le
continent oui absolument et est donc le
bon bleus
la référence à de gaulle elle est
presque si vous voulez pour un président
de la république quelle que soit sa
couleur politique un président français
de la vème république une référence
évidemment obligé mais c'est une à la
fois une façon de si vous voulez d'auto
légitimation il ya toujours une un effet
miroir là dedans en fonction de la
figure l'on se choisit comme modèle et
c'est alors il ya alors que les manceaux
d'accord mais ça avait été déjà pris
aussi par par manuel valls ont accès à
une époque nicolas sarkozy nous avait
fait croire qu'ils avaient rédigé un
bouquin sur georges mandel
il avait peut-être en effet écrit la
préface où la conclusion
mais cette référence historique
elle a un côté très vème république et
un côté aussi très français ont le bon
l'entente moins c'est ce type de
référence par exemple dans les discours
de président étasunien on l'entend
nettement mois dans la vie politique
allemande
on peut comprendre aux italiennes il ya
quelque chose de très de très construit
en tout cas est le seul fait de devoir
un président de la république dans le de
le voir s'immerger dans un contexte
historique relatifs à notre histoire
notre histoire construite à notre récit
national contribue à asseoir la
légitimité de la fonction soit c'est à
c'est un grand classique
alors malheureusement obligés de se
quitter
juste un mot peut-être jean charest
jeudi sur stéphane bourgoin parce que
vous êtes éditeur notamment de polars et
si c'était le spécialiste des séries l
islet on s'aperçoit petit il a tout
inventé et s'aperçoit que c'est un
serial menteur qu'il a déclaré avoir eu
lorsqu'il n'est pas en soi très très
grave
lago enfin il se vantait d'avoir
recueilli les confidences de plus de 70
serial killer si l'on en croit ses
déclarations dans mal s'il en aurait vu
peut-être deux et croiser 40 dans les
couloirs mais croisés c'est à dire que
n'importe quel visiteur de prison et
même chose alors ça ça c'est juste de la
fabulation ce qui est beaucoup plus
gênant c'est qu'il a construit son sans
avoir construit sa réputation autour du
meurtre absolument horrible de sa femme
aurait été victime d'un serial killer
or c'était pas sa femme et voilà donc
c'est quand même la une on est au delà
de l'ignominie
c'est à dire que me faire pleurer dans
les chaumières sur une femme qui
n'existe pas et un serial killer qu'on
ne va pas ça c'est proprement scandaleux
après au delà du personnage pas très
sympathique et
et pour le mac certaines connaissances
venir dit de nant depuis 40 ans il finit
par quand même fini par connaître le
sujet enfin n'importe qui passaient 40
ans à pomper les bouquins des autres sur
les serial killers finirait par en être
une sorte d'expert
donc je ne me renie pas ça du tout mais
mais ça me rappelle une autre réflexion
c'est que il y avait une fascination et
peut-être at-elle toujours lieu dans les
salons comment stéphane bourgoin arrive
il ya 200 personnes
très souvent des femmes qui font la
queue on en venir se faire signer un
bouquin et ça me ça me rappelle toutes
ces femmes qui qui font la queue pour
discuter avec des prisonniers avec des
criminels qui ce qui tombe en
véritablement amoureuse mais aussi bien
qu'ils écrivent à marc dutroux comme à
tout comme à tous les plus grands
prédateurs qui sont fascinés et c'est
cette fascination pour le mal et le et
l'ultra man qui est quand même
extrêmement inquiétante alors elle se
manifeste pour marc dutroux pour
stéphane bourgoin et c'est je pense
c'est un peu la même clientèle
moi j'ai beau éditer des romans
policiers cette fascination pour le
serial killer et sa façon qu'il aurait
déposé ses victimes en leur arrachant
moteur à manu voilà je trouve ça ça en
dit peut-être beaucoup sur une certaine
catégorie de population
voilà c'est un peu inquiétant merci
juste avant la pause pour finir alors
oui ou non
veillon les mémoires de woody allen
niveau c'est bon sortir florence
mercatello alayli vous êtes choqué par
les accusations mais une énième stéphane
en son nom moi je veux je crois que je
ne les lirai pas mais je suis je suis
profondément rassurés que c'est que cet
ouvrage puisse puisse paraître on va les
regarder ses films plutôt que de passer
moi et marne ou non à caution je ne
l'aimé pas ah bon vous n'êtes pas non
non parce que ça ne m'intéresse pas ça
ne le savais même pas polémique 1 c'est
parce qu'il est d'accord quant à moi
bien évidemment je vais lire parler
parcourir mais pas les coudées pas
l'élire de a à z et il aurait été ravi
de les publier je me serais battu pour
les publier
nommé indispensable qu'on puisse publier
ce genre de livre voilà après on en
pense qu'on en veut on aime on n'aime
pas mais voilà c'est scandaleux qu aux
etats unis le l'éditeur se doivent se
soit débat donnait enfin c'est vraiment
un tout visiblement mes gars là tu l'as
dit oui
il n'a pas voulu ma part je savais qu'il
y en aurait plein qui serait porteur et
oui la mobilité voilà c'est sur ces
paroles combattons pas se quitter merci
merci beaucoup katrina d'avoir été avec
vous merci beaucoup feront ce mercredi
ce look et c'est à mon sens et jean
charles lajoie nice et puis on se
retrouve très vite pour un nouveau
numéro de poste au revoir
[Musique]